[Music]
here in this video we will present to
you the 13 predator ranks and status in
ascending order starting from the babies
to the very old and the ruling class
this will reveal to you the air key and
the classification of predators
according to their abilities and
achievements
so let's get to it
firstly the suckling
this isn't a rang or a title or anything
or any achievement related it's just
that we have to start somewhere and
where else but the baby stage young
predators are called sucklings and they
only become adults after 50 to 60 years
of age which by their standards is
equivalent to an 18 year old human since
they age very slow
they probably would have minor trading
entertaining this age
number two the unblooded this is the
second stage on the life of a predator
and these are called the unblooded
because they haven't finished their
basic training and also haven't secured
a kill
in the blooding ritual which could
either be a cinema of kill or another
deadly alien like a river ghost or a
human in the main timelines
number three the young blood this is a
yautja rang mainly composed of
adolescents that have just completed
their basic training regimen some clans
do not have young blood rank with their
unblooded jumping straight to bloodied
after the ritual other clans such as the
dark blade glands distinguish between
unblooded and young blood hunters in
accordance to their readiness for the
blooding ritual
number four the blooded this is the rang
young blood yajja attained after
successfully killing their prey and
marking themselves with their blood
notably the xenomorph species or a river
ghost or some deadly alien species
blooding is a sign that a yautja is
trusted to hunt alone without the
supervision of superiors this is similar
to the coming of age rituals of many
human tribes
number 5 the adjeton these are recently
blooded predators with a reasonable
level of experience and kills adjutants
accompany a leader responsible for tasks
such as ship navigation and piloting
they also function as secondary
overseers and often carry their leaders
mark having been previously blooded by
them
they may rise to the position of a
leader by challenging the current leader
of that pack
number six the hunters these are
experienced predators and are quite
capable of undertaking dangerous stars
alone without the help of a pack or
subordinates like adjutants they also
are back leaders in certain instances
the jungle and city hunters are perfect
examples of such predators in this rank
their skills are highly developed as
well as their hunting intuitiveness
which makes them a deadly threat to
everything
number 7 the elites also called veterans
the elites are one of the top levels in
the predator air key they have skills
like none others and a large number of
kills
it means that elites are the general
foundation of the more dangerous
predators and counted and are
most likely the reason why predator race
is seen as close to unbeatable by humans
that are forced to face them a wolf from
avp requiem is a good example of an
elite
number 8 the enforcers enforcers are yao
ja that hold a special ranking
within the predator culture unlike other
yaouja that hun worthy game enforcers
hold the position of hunting down rogue
bad bloods that have disgraced the
yautja name and putting an end to their
existence
they are mostly very honorable and
distinguished elites that act as a
police force amongst their species
number nine the elder
they are accomplished long-lived yautja
warriors who are distinguished from
other blooded and elite ranks for their
battle prowess or leadership at certain
occasions an elder also jointly holds
the title of a clan leader they are all
hunters who have accomplished countless
hunts over many years having cultivated
and brandished their own unique hunting
and fighting styles greyback from
predator 2 is one such elder
number 10 the ancient an ancient is a
yautja that is older than elder
one that is close to or have surpassed a
thousand years of age and has survived
countless hunts and battles they are
usually not clan leaders but are loyal
and valued advisers to an existing clan
leader their age prevents them from
actively hunting and battling but are
still worthy foes in any circumstance
the old predator from avp alien vs
predator the first movie was an ancient
number 11 the leader clan leaders are
one of the highest attainable ranks in
yao ja society
they rule near absolutely within their
own clans commanding many less skilled
warriors and even elders and ancients
clan leaders are sometimes known to don
long red capes that are only
seen in them and no other yautja wears
it they often lead other predators to
missions of world on behalf of the
supreme leader of the yautjas
number 12 the matriarch this is an
equivalent of a leader of the predator
clans and she is a female while male
clan leaders lead the males in of world
matters the matriarchs rule and resolve
on world things the males act only as a
substitute or instead of a matriarch
which means that her power and authority
supersedes the leader of her clan
although they are rare they still exist
in the predator society
and 13 the predator king
this predator is a very old powerful and
mysterious supreme leader of the
predators and as such is a rare
occurrence in their society but still
happens on certain occasions
the predator king supersedes the
matriarchs as well and rule over a group
of clans and even maybe the entire
yautja race
and he sits on top of a throne made of
xenomorph trophies and other deadly
races
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam